she's been [ __ ] on me to everyone
like sophia gave the worst sex book ever
to me like she's bad at recommending
those books i'm sorry it's not an
erotica if you read 29 chapters only to
get the sex from the cat's point of view
hey everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwaxed podcast
with your favorite sisters sophia and
sistine stallone you guys i know we have
been m.i.a we are aware and i understand
we said that the last time we put out an
episode and now you're wondering
where are they
looking around in the background here
you're probably like this is not their
normal zoom session at in their house um
in a random studio in a kitchen in a
kitchen we actually
decided we should become a legit podcast
and do what everyone else does and get a
set we decided to grow up a little bit
yeah because i think we're kind of over
the let's just upload see who listens
see what gets picked up and
and here we are thank you to malka
studios now we are signed with them we
have this beautiful set they built for
us and actually what i love about the
set that we're sitting on right now
we gave them a vision we told them
exactly what we wanted and this looks
like what we wished our apartment looks
like that's the best way to describe it
you know what i mean we said we wanted
something with character something that
defines us
girly with edge on it with some lights a
little bit masky a little bit sexy i
mean they nailed it they nailed it every
single piece so if you're listening to
this go watch it because it's definitely
worth it and also you get to watch us
and yes today we put on makeup this time
and we didn't just hope that the low
quality zoom camera video you know i do
have to say though
i posted a tick tock the other day yeah
and all of these men started commenting
um
put down the makeup brushes because they
said we were wearing too much makeup why
i'm aware i'm the one putting it on my
face i know i wear a lot of makeup okay
as bad as when you come downstairs and
your mom goes you know you look really
tired
i just i slept eight hours actually i
actually do have three layers of
concealer on but i'm aware that i'm
doing it so don't call me out anyway
sorry for the rest just like when we put
on makeup we're giving ourselves like a
nice upgraded facelift we decided to do
that with the podcast yes and it is
we're super excited because
we have so many things planned when i
say so many things i mean you guys are
in for a wild ride we are going to talk
about crazy topics we have such exciting
guests especially the one next week
we'll bring up a little bit we have more
listener involvement and it's all
happening every tuesday and i mean that
this time we are putting out content
every single tuesday and our instagram
page and everything else will not look
as sloppy as it has been since the scene
i've gotten everything together and here
we are here we are episode 49 when we
hit episode 50. we're calling it season
two baby
that was weird that was great actually i
think that was a lot better than i
thought a little bit of telepathy there
okay i think we should just go right
into our weekly update i guess it should
be
several weeks of update because it's
been a minute to talk about i mean but
even this past week i feel like there's
we just have an endless supply of things
that have been going on i think we
should kick it off with something that
has been giving you
such unnecessary anxiety you've been
talking about dealing with your quarter
life crisis for i don't know how many
months now you know it was the problem
is like i've been telling people i'm 25
for the past six months that is weird
isn't it weird i remember my ex used to
get mad at me because i'd always say
when it hit a certain point like i think
february is my six months until my
actual birthday i know oh yeah i'm 23.
he's like no you're 22. stop saying
you're 23. but what gave you such
anxiety about turning 25 because i had
this idea in my head that i would
probably be
maybe getting married soon maybe have my
own place maybe like financially it's
just at least a little bit more stable i
think that when you're young you have
this idea of where you need to be when
you're 25 and i was like
i don't even know how to make proper
breakfast and i was gonna say i'm gonna
be so straight up how are you supposed
to take care of someone else if you
could barely take care of yourself i
literally might my my my like uh mental
state and my relationship status is
hanging on by a threat so
i don't even know where i had this idea
that i'd have anything figured out but
yeah you guys i'm the big two five and
were you freaking out for nothing i woke
up in the yes i did definitely okay i
was a bit over dramatic on my birthday
cake it said happy quarter life crisis
by the way i decorated your cake so well
can we give it a moment can we tell
people what we did on my birthday so
i'll just explain really quick what i
decided to do for my party but overall
if you guys are scared to turn a certain
age it doesn't really matter you wake up
the same day and you're like ah it's the
same it's the same people people are
definitely listening to this 35 saying
shut the [ __ ] up sophia you're 25 you're
in your mid-20s you're peaking right i
actually think 25 sounds sexy i'm like
oh
oh wow okay good whatever so um woke up
everything was great so steam was
awesome i think cynthia tried to run
into my room but i was still sleeping
because i was so anxious about my
birthday no you didn't sleep
this is what bothers me about sophia
she'll always beat you to it like you
you'll never let me have the moment and
and surprise you you have to
for example
i was going okay let me make the coffee
for the first time for sophia and i'm
gonna be the one that runs in here i
make coffee and tackles her on her bed
on her birthday
no i go i check at her room she's
sleeping i go back to my bed 15 minutes
later you come in my room like it's my
birthday and i was like sophia
let me
surprise you
i'm like hey it's my birthday and she's
like sophia i could have came into your
room but that was fun i've been planning
this party dinner thing for the past few
weeks and i was so anxious i don't know
if anyone else feels this way i hate
throwing parties for myself i do not
like having the responsibility of
texting people and telling them to show
up to my dinner or my party i see you're
very working i was getting honestly it
was giving me highs i'm great at
celebrating anybody else's give me your
day and i will celebrate and make it the
best party for you but when it's for me
i'm like what if someone hates me
because i didn't invite them what if
someone uh can't come and i invite
someone else or whatever or someone
invites their friend to come with us but
it
ended up being fine but we went to a
dinner it was a group of 12 girls and
then after we went to this little like
outdoor club thing it was just kind of
fun
just being all of your friends an
extension of your friends but the best
part was before the dinner what we did
so we decided to get there a little
early
and okay well i have a backstory so
i decided for some reason it would be a
good idea to dye my hair black on
sophia's birthday
when i say black i mean she does it so i
i just you know
i don't know why i keep doing it to
myself but i've done it about four times
in quarantine now yeah and i go let me
just
make a very risky choice but you do this
on a big day this is on a big date on a
big time though so for the bulk of your
birthday i was
in the salon chair
regretting all of my choices but can we
also just acknowledge the fact that my
sister's probably gone to five different
hair stylists in the last month
five it's like dating though finding a
good hairdresser is like dating i found
mine you just
stick with it well i didn't
get along with him like you get along
with that's true you know we don't have
the same type of people we date just
like we don't have the same hairdresser
type so i'm dyeing my hair black so i
was planning on decorating sophia's cake
with a bunch of drunk barbies you know
obscure images and maybe some
half naked men on the cake yeah good
representation yeah yeah why not that i
like i didn't have time to do any of
that so sofia and i thought it'd be a
good idea in the middle of the
restaurant to put the cake on the floor
put the cake on the floor and start
decorating a cake
in the middle of the restaurant with a
plastic bag full of all these toys and
this is a nice place it's definitely the
first time they've ever seen two girls
do this and i'm holding the cake and i'm
calling barbies yeah and this is in
front of the whole restaurant like hey
can we just put this on the floor and
start creating something and they go
what do you mean we're like let me
create let me just create this cake so
she does we are literally in the middle
of the restaurant sticking drunk barbies
toilets um like the barbie is kind of
looking like it was throwing up we put
some like champagne is it worth it
yes the candles had butts on them it was
so funny i worked hard on it but i feel
like your whole birthday was a success
it was and for some reason you know you
always have an expectation going into
whatever you plan and sometimes it never
meets that standard and you get
disappointed but for the first time we
woke up in the morning saying that was
just the perfect night but what do you
think made it perfect
well we were saying that how we figured
out that last that night was the perfect
night was just every person was on the
same wavelength like everyone's energy
was there like everyone was there to
have a good time there was not one
person on how many drinks did you have
oh my god um
like i literally said oh my god i think
i had i started with champagne
two tequilas i had two tequila shots
then i went to that place and probably
had a lot more oh then my friend handed
me a mini cos amigos bottle oh god you
drank like a fish i drink like a fish my
goodness there's a reason why i was
thinking i woke up in the morning going
why didn't anyone uh give me a birthday
kiss
probably because i was probably because
you were face down ass off
they were like what do we kiss
where's where's her face so he's hiking
in a bush like what does she do i just
remember running around to like 100
different people but if you're wondering
what the secret sauce for fun party is
it's just drama just kidding i said this
but i know you did that's why i'm
bringing it up right you had you had
more time than me sophia i was just
having sophia said this multiple times
on the podcast that what makes a night
fun is throwing a little bit of spicy
drama well i said i want drama on my
birthday but i don't want it to be about
me so of course
it was about i gave it to sistine
i walk in
and the first person i see
is someone that i have been
see i'm pissed because
i know you're listening right now
i know you're listening right now and
it's a flat i kind of give zero [ __ ] at
this point so how are you doing
i like your haircut i think you should
buzz your hair in my opinion anyway i
told him that i'm telling him right now
okay
um the first person i see when i walk in
is my ex and he comes up to me and he
goes
it was one of those exes that
you know didn't really need to didn't
end bad didn't really need to break up
so definitely on good terms and have
wanted to catch up with him for a first
time on your mind yeah and so i was i
was really happy to see him
the first thing he says to me is
stop talking about me on your podcast
and i said
so you're a listener okay sorry not a
boxer so you're are you subscribed
that's what i said i hope that by the
way that night i had so many people
coming up to me referencing like guys
things on my podcast going like oh i
didn't realize watching wolf of wall
street was a red flag i go well how did
you know that that was like four weeks
ago what i love what i love so much
about our listeners
is they're a little bit toxic like us
because he told me he could be lying but
he told me
people that i didn't even know were
dm'ing me this episode saying is this
about you so you and waxers are real
ones out there i love it you've got my
back i'm just throwing you under the no
because they know what i like
because then we have content to talk
about yeah they're giving me the car and
then you met some nice guys there you
had you did well
you did well i totally forgot i had the
bouncer just following me around the
whole night
i had a great night because i met a guy
the night of your birthday you did and
we went on a date last night
so steve went on a date i know we
because it's usually it's just not
booking them out all the time but it's
no it's you cecine look it's been a
minute and i honestly forgot how to date
i'm proud of myself because i invited
this person and i had a feeling i was
like you know you did not have a feeling
you didn't even put in one ounce of
grafting for me so not true that is so
not true
you're going literally you should talk
to her dancing on the table you do not
try to grasp for me one time
i've been like you go over there so i
don't know what came over me that night
but there were some for the first time
in a long time i feel like
i was confident and i don't normally
walk into a room or a party feeling a
hundred percent comfortable with myself
i'm always like oh my god my hair my
dress or the wrong freaking shoes and
then i always think back to myself no
one actually gives a [ __ ] about the
color of your shoes christine so just
enjoy your night but for the first time
i actually felt
comfortable in my skin which is
something that i woke up the next day
actually telling my mom about and i was
like i don't know why i feel like i have
to share this but
i feel like i get it i feel like i get
it you know what i mean because she
always tells you
oh when you hit a certain age there's
going to be a click eventually in your
life where you just stop caring and you
just start living for you yeah and i
sort of had that click that night and i
wasn't even drunk you guys i swear i
just felt really good and so that also
gave me the confidence to walk up to
this guy because i thought he was cute
and i walk up to him and i give him a
hug and i say hey how are you and he
looks at me goes good and walks away and
i go
it's love at first sight you guys know
what a guy
is when he just says one word but that
didn't knock me cuz guess what we ended
up going on a date and i had a really
great time but i feel like that's the
key to it and i like i want to swing
back around because sometimes we forget
like i've had so many nights where i've
gone to a room and i'm like oh god my
outfit looks bad my hair looks bad my
makeup no one gives a [ __ ]
how you look and i even felt confident
that night that's why i was running
around to every single person talking to
whoever i wanted to talk to and then yes
maybe the tequila gave me some courage
there
but i mean when you kind of go in not
having any reservations on yourself you
have no idea the people you can meet the
situations that you you can be put in
and look at if you maybe if you didn't
say hi to him you never know like things
could come up you guys would probably go
out later but i'm saying
and you did do it and he said planted
that seed and it swung back around and
look at you know now you had a date and
it was awesome so wait what because i
asked you a little bit about it this
morning um and we don't have to get into
like detailed detail but
what was the difference between
these because i you came in different
like i felt an energy on you that was
more relaxing yes i was very tranquil
yeah which is odd because normally when
you come in for dates you kind of are
jumping around going that was so amazing
i'm trying to overcompensate for the
fact that it was actually a terrible day
that's the key and i try to make it work
i think
i've been single i haven't been in a
relationship for a long time so i think
i've been trying to force
the dates that i do go on yeah just
hoping that that person is gonna have
some qualities that would be
you know a good match for me in a
relationship and a lot of the time or
should i say all of the time all the
time it's not the case and i try to make
up excuses for them and and try to be
overly excited to also get your guys's
approval of him and right only to find
out that it doesn't work about a few
weeks later but what was different this
time around was for the first time i
feel like wow i'm having a lot of first
time realizations you guys this is crazy
it's the new moon in virgo
you shut the [ __ ] up
literally leave
you did not just say that oh my god i
just realized what i did this morning
and you're gonna make fun of me so bad
about it oh wait i did something too but
you go first oh my god i don't know why
this is so embarrassing so yeah the new
moon is in virgo and i was on tick tock
late last night and someone told me to
do something and i did it so this
morning wait talk breathe
you haven't taken a single breath i'm so
embarrassed i'm pitching myself i didn't
literally realize like i almost like
so um
they said okay right it's like a good
time for manifestation so write out
what you want to manifest
and put it under a crystal leave it in
the movement
and that's only if you want to and it
says fold the paper towards you and
write it in present time like it is
already happening so i wrote down five
actually because i have i want a lot of
things i wrote six things on um i like i
remember i like added on the bottom like
wait wait
you're like psi one more thing is like i
realized all the things i added were
super selfish and i was like oh wait i
should probably add one about love like
have a relationship you don't have to
yeah well no it was just kind of like
you know i was like the world of better
people so i wrote this i wrote it and i
folded it and i didn't put under the
moonlight i don't have any crystals um
and so
you have no i don't i don't
i've been wanting to buy them i don't
have any but i put it under like a
really uh my necklace that i like love
that means a lot to me so wait listen
listen so this morning um i like for
completely forgot about it and i saw it
by my bedside i'm like oh shoot i still
have it and so i'm like what do i do
with this paper like i don't want anyone
to see it and the guy says you
you have to go outside and burn it into
the sunlight burn it so i go outside on
the balcony literally right outside your
door this morning you're a hazard and i
like lit it on fire and i kept like um
missing it and the ashes were going
everywhere so i'm trying to burn this
paper so i literally did a ritual this
morning burning the paper so that it
might be a witch my manifestations would
just go into the sun following the new
moon in virgo don't even get me started
the fact that i did this all before this
podcast
you know i thought we were different but
i genuinely don't know how we are
related sometimes because that is
something i would never do nothing wrong
with doing it if you're into that that's
fine but this just what came out of your
mouth i never thought like i had to
reset the match like a hundred times so
i literally probably used like all of
the matches to get this thing to burn
what have you been up to lately i don't
know what has been going on in your room
that i don't know first of all
it's kind of a dual purpose one i don't
want anyone to see me writing these
things down and make fun of me just like
you are now if i said if i saw you
outside my window this morning try to
set a piece of paper on fire
i don't know
i would have said cancel the show i was
like letting the energy of the paper
going little do you know like the ashes
set the backyard on fire and you're
phone yeah this is the best part is so
that i saw the ashes starting go like
they're drifting i'm like oh [ __ ] so i
had i ran inside got my water bottle i'm
like
well then your intentions are soaked
you could completely just have it
defeated this is the best part it's like
this is why i'm not good at this half of
my paper was burnt half of it was just
drenched so water what part was drenched
i thought you wrote because that means
that's not coming true it's happening
but it didn't catch fire didn't release
into the sun within it
enough did i think so at least like 98
of it will be coming true i did ask for
some pretty ridiculous things so i don't
know i do some weird stuff okay at least
one thing that i manifested was that i
in the next five years will be able to
purchase my first home with the money
that we made that's cool you're on wax
or whatever jobs i get and a company i
build and so that was just like one goal
that's a good one yeah and then i also
wrote that um i do talks at usc and um
to campuses around the world about
mental health and about um doing a
business startup because i really love
like my favorite class at usu is taking
the leap so and it was all about
entrepreneurs i'm like i want to be on
that stage so that and then also i wrote
that i um i'm always surrounded by very
influential uh game changers of the
world like sarah blakely oprah like
really like i want to meet all these
people so that was really three of the
six but also a relationship i wrote
something of sweet john about that oh
yeah i had this thought in my head going
what if i have all this stuff and then i
don't feel like i just have all this
money and just nothing to do no man i'm
basically citizens kane like i'm just
sitting by myself in my mansion
generally doing nothing else she was
like i just have just so many crystals
and not a single boyfriend yeah so i did
say that um i did say that
i would find um my soul mate who is
super ambitious motivates me kind
hilarious um adventurous you know
honestly as much as i make fun of you i
do think that
you would what you put out and what you
attract is going to come back to you
yeah i do think that because you're
subconsciously
seeking it all you know what it is too
is like sometimes i know yeah okay it
sounds like hoodoo voodoo to say
um
to go oh like you're writing it down
paper manifesting it but i think about
it and talk about it so much they almost
i feel like it's ingrained in my brain
though yeah you do you're very into it
yeah and it doesn't even mean it's
supposed to be like whether or not
energy and that type of stuff works yeah
i just think in my head
because i've said it so many times that
it it has to like look to each their own
and that's what i love about our
relationship is that we are so different
and i sometimes do try to take a page
out of your book for example i tried
journaling did you was that what we were
trying to tell me
before this um
no i want to hear what you were doing
before this
it's uh i read i read i was trying to
read something about virgo in the new
moon i was reading what my horoscope was
for this week yeah and i didn't like
what they told me so i was just ignoring
you well they're liars so that's not
happening but i tried to you know
meditate and we all know that didn't
work out for me i tried to journal
and then you know six months later i
read back my journal entries and
i remember reading out loud i was like
i was such a loser i was like why did i
let this kid get me so upset like so i
can't take myself seriously in those
ways i like to bottle everything can i
tell you honestly i so i have a journal
that i i call it my journal but i
honestly just use it literally once in a
blue moon and i look back at some of the
entries and i make fun of myself so much
about how dramatic i was or whatever but
honestly i love that i still have that
stuff because i'm like look at that
relationship that was i i remember i was
writing about a boy that i was seeing
that um it was right after the big
breakup it was the um the
uh baseball player guy
you're already baseball player dude yeah
that's just not even going to wait but
yeah and i was talking out so highly of
him and so like how much i really like
him and then now looking back on that
today i'm like oh my god i roll your
eyes i roll my eyes but it's funny i'm
like i'm glad i got to see like what was
going on in that moment like how i was
feeling and then it's a flashback i
think we should bring in our journals
one of these episodes and just read them
live on the show oh my god i know yeah i
actually you know i want to bring in
that we've said what we would do we
should bring in the letters that our
exes wrote for us i want to do that but
that is pretty [ __ ] in high school
that's like that's still someone's
feelings and you know me i'm so into
that by the way let's blast them but if
we're gonna be real between the two of
us you think my ex for my school is at
all listening to the show you know where
he is right now not here in the states
they're all trying to find themselves in
some country they are uh should i get
back to my date yes please so
what
i liked about this date yeah what was
different from the other ones
sometimes i feel like
i go for the kind of guy not sometimes
all of the time i feel like i go for the
kind of guy that is the loudest in the
room has to be the show off has to
assert some sort of dominance has to be
somewhat bad boy and and you know kind
of leave you
uneasy all the time and like bad boys
are exciting but they're not going to
text you back
bad boys are cool but they're not gonna
pick you up bad boys uh
leave you with this cat mouse chase but
they're
never gonna check if you got home safe
oh and like does leave you with also a
toxic mindset exactly and then they [ __ ]
you up so like they're fun in theory
yeah but i've realized i'm like okay
that's not what i want and that's not
who i am and i think i was trying
honestly you know how some people are
like you date your parents like you you
d sometimes boys or sons date people
that look like their mom and like
there's always traits like his mom
no no definitely not that's what i'm
saying i'm saying i think i
sort of would go out with people that
resembled sly a little bit just like
crazy loud
loudest in the room kind of guy energy
which is so much fun and it worked for
my mom but that doesn't work for me
so you know what it is is mom's not like
that right it was a good workout
you are like that and so am i and i
think that we think the bad boys like
because they're the loudest they're the
coolest are going to be the ones that
are the most fun but you don't need to
have like there are nice guys and that's
funny that's why i think i left really
happy because it almost felt
comforting to know that
i didn't feel like i was
being used or played or or i had to put
on a different hat for this guy like i
genuinely just felt myself which is
really nice well i think that's i mean
we can speak for ourselves i know for us
like a lot of the times when we date we
feel like we have to put on a
facade in a way because that's what
people perceive us especially if they
don't know us initially and then once
you get to know us you realize okay
they're actually just very very yeah
normal honestly this one was a total
success and i'm really excited
uh well that's something that people
should know yeah and i do definitely in
the next few episodes i've had some
crazy
crazy horrible dates that are almost
good enough to be their own bedtime
stories that i will share with you guys
as i say you should say oh my god you
guys they are incredible so for the
first time in a long time
successful
nice guys finished last yeah kind of day
but that's something to know if you guys
are going out with someone whether it's
a girl or a guy whoever you're going out
with
the way to tell that this might be
different is how comfortable you are
with them right off the bat that you're
not going through everyone's resumes or
backgrounds of who they dated you don't
even talk about that you can talk about
anything else yeah other than that yeah
he just didn't make me feel nervous and
you don't have to overcompensate too you
know i was i was watching uh so
embarrassing this is where i get my
facts from but i was watching a tick
tock
and i'm not sure which celebrity said
this it could be halsey it could be demi
lovato
i'm not sure someone of that of that
world okay
and they said um a lot of people
associate getting butterflies in your
stomach when you're with a person to be
a nervous exciting feeling
but you should look at the butterflies
in your stomach as
your body telling you
that's a red flag and your body is
warning you like this person makes me
feel uneasy yeah
and so i started looking at it
differently and um that's actually very
interesting it's an interesting take
because some people are like oh i'm
nervous excited but it could be your
body saying like there's something that
doesn't sit well with me with this
person right
now i'm gonna think about it absolutely
true maybe no it's good i think that
totally because i feel like if it's not
i mean i know the differences between
the people i've dated long term and the
people that i've had like a three-month
relationship with and the ones that were
the three months were the ones i was
still kind of giving
some i was pushing the reasons why i
like them more rather than just saying
yeah it just works also i just i also
last last point on this um
there's i think we grew up with this
whole fantasy of
love at first sight and you're supposed
to find this insane initial attraction
and it's supposed to click right away
even like the first kiss is supposed to
be unreal but i don't think that's the
case and i genuinely think you can grow
to like someone more and more and you
don't have to have this you know
overwhelming flood of like this is the
one when you first go on a date with
someone maybe you do and you're lucky if
you do but you know also and i just want
to encourage people to do this and i
know look
dating apps are great like they get you
dates and you talk to people constantly
at the snap of fingers
but i highly encourage everyone to not
use that and try to meet people the
natural way which is in person because
it says us that i know three hours it's
better to do that i feel like because
you but no i really i mean yes it's
harder especially right now but you met
this guy naturally and it just worked
out naturally and i feel like those are
the ones that you should end up with so
we'll see yeah should we give them
an apartment update you guys guys my
uh
so we we started this journey with you
guys you've been there for every step of
of the apartment hunting purchasing
furnishing you've been there for all of
it now
it's been nothing but disaster
disaster thank you for the dramatics
disaster it's been horrible but no look
living
with sistine and our cousin ryan has
been fun it is an eye-opening it's been
eye-opening it's been
better than i expected now that we don't
like share cars and things like that
like you got your car into the place
like that was a big pain in the ass
before but also drive me anywhere no i
didn't but you also took him regardless
and even living with the guy is so
different yeah but now it's the
apartment itself that is giving us
see so
we thought we found a little gold nugget
with this place we go oh my god
three bedroom for this rent
we hit the jackpots no we we purchased a
broken apartment let me tell you we were
idiots and didn't ask any questions
and and so the past 48 hours has been a
lot for me with this place we've had no
ac
we have
two
leaks coming from the ceiling let's just
say there's three air vents and two of
the three broke down so we had no air
for the first two months of our place we
have two leaks coming out of the ceiling
so i can't use my shower bath or sink
and neither can sustain because it's
actually we woke up to our entire living
room flooded uh family room flooded so
all of the pipes are backed up yeah we
have mold apparently
someone decided that was living there
before us that it'd be a good idea to
cut all of the electrical wires in my
room so i have no working outlets no
outlets um oh yeah someone messed with
my door so i couldn't get into my
bathroom for a couple days yeah i got a
locksmith to
break down the door yes
it's just pile after pilot oh now we
have holes in our ceiling because we do
have giant holes in our ceiling and our
closets so
what really set me off
was
i go in there i'm trying to
you know
figure out okay do we stay do we go
should we just
leave this this lease
and
a cockroach
comes up to me
and at that point i said buddy hear the
keys the place is yours
you want to take my room move in i was
like you get the upstair master the
place is yours i'm out but i'm pissed at
you by the way what did i do
i'm pissed at you because
you said
we're moving out
okay
i spent no you said we're moving and you
agreed no
not really ryan and i talked about this
no no when the leak happened we said
ryan i looked at each other we're like
the only person that is going to pop off
is sistine ryan and i were like okay we
can fix this we'll get out of the place
for a couple days you popped off you're
like i'm out and we're like really and
you're like i'm out i'm done you did
tell me we're moving out and we agreed
you said that after i spent 10 hours
alone
moving
all of my [ __ ] out i don't have a sock
left there well that's not fair because
then whoa did i finish my rant
i go back to the house i have all of my
stuff but you also
did a hasty decision
that wasn't my decision i bring
everything back i hang everything back
up now you're only to find out that
sophia goes you know what this place
isn't that bad actually i think you
should stay
i never said it was a bad place you said
it was a bad place also not my fault
that you decided
out of the blue to get everything out of
that place i didn't think you were going
to move
everything out like i'm going to stay at
the house for a bit until all of our
plumbing and everything is working
but you were instantly like we're done
you're like and then you said mom's
friend said something that triggered you
to get out just a miscommunication a
little bit of miscommunication
but yes the place isn't horrible it's
just all the [ __ ] that's going on with
the place it's horrible we have roaches
no air
broken pipes it's really testing our
adulthood right now yeah
we're really getting hit in the face a
lot with these are we are so our entire
place oh yeah and also the best
i think the best part about where we
live is that there's [ __ ] that goes down
on our street all the time i know last
time i talked about this big car
accident that happened at 4 am that no
one heard and the guy fled the scene and
everyone was confused about where this
guy was running the other day there was
just like seven different cop cars it's
so funny outside raiding our neighbor i
would i would touch sophia at 7 am going
hey look outside your window look what's
happening this morning and there's like
three people i'm not gonna say my
street's name but i want to do like the
the blank gazette like just literally
every single day or every literally
every other day yep there's [ __ ] that
goes down it's fun it's definitely just
it's busy it's fun i love living with a
guy i think it's amazing it's so great
because we get to see the other side
also he gets to bring his friends over
that's true and i try to go out with one
of them didn't end up being a good idea
yeah it wasn't a good idea no i
cancelled that very fast why
it was just too close to home you know i
uh
he went out with one of my girlfriends
and so i was kind of like you know
i didn't like how that's situated so i'm
just not gonna do the same thing for him
i just think when it comes to that stuff
when you're living with someone maybe
just keep it separate yeah you know you
want to keep it you know what they say
there are plenty of fish in the sea yeah
i actually hate that saying i hate when
people say there's plenty of fish
i'm swimming in there which ocean are we
in
i feel like i'm in a pool
there's no fish in that pool i'm in a
hot tub actually i got one little fish
right now yeah you do shut up i got a
little guppy in there i got nothing i'm
in the pool on the shallow end in other
news we dropped scarlet off at college
oh which was absolutely hysterical
heinous horrible it was actually really
funny when we dropped her off and we
were saying
do you remember this halfway we were
saying the final goodbye we were hugging
her we're hysterically crying my mom's
crying scarlet's crying and we watch her
drive off and as we're all standing
there no makeup knowing like bawling
this girl this really pretty girl
beautiful blonde czech comes up to us i
actually remember her name her name is
sam
sam if you're listening hi
um she comes up to us and goes
i just have to let you guys know i love
the podcast and i was like oh my god
you're standing here looking so gorgeous
we look like wet rats yeah literally we
look swollen it was higher she was so
cute she was so cute so it did it was
like a bittersweet moment because yeah
someone left but then at the same time
someone acknowledged that we actually
had a podcast still yes we almost forgot
absolutely
my mom was standing there she's like are
you guys happy i'm like i don't know how
to feel because a hysterical squirrel is
leaving but we have a fan but it just
looks cool every time someone comes up
to us and says we love the show we go
really we're like why why do we do that
we can't we literally go are you sure
you're like is it ours i know is it
other two sisters that have a show i
know i have a bad habit of not taking a
compliment i can't take a compliment but
i think it's rude when you don't you
know what i mean i think it's just i
mean you don't have to be cocky about it
i think it's appropriate to be saying
like you know thank you for saying that
you can also give them well i just think
it's a bad habit and i think
if someone offers to do something nice
or someone compliments you
take it you know don't like [ __ ] on
yourself and say oh no i'm actually
you know feeling really ugly today so i
don't know why you'd say i look nice
like don't do that you know yeah you
know what's funny i was just thinking
about this on the flight home i love the
feeling of not checking my phone for a
while and then when it you turn off
airplane mode and you land
what you saw that you wrote that and i
took it you [ __ ] stole my bit
[ __ ] you
yeah i only wrote this down i normally
don't write down bits you guys but i
wrote this down because
for a reason and you can't first of all
you delivered it terribly and you have
no context to what it means i actually
do because no you kind of sparked an
idea let me yeah okay so i only wrote
this down because i can't i'm a content
stealer yeah you really are i caught i
caught myself doing something really
funny and embarrassing so when i was
flying home
from uh the college that we were
visiting scarlet i
i um first i always get
weird things that happened to me on
planes mm-hmm i was watching mamma mia i
cried four times that's like a crying
movie though i know but i don't know if
i was crying because i missed scarlet or
i kind of wanted that life and it wasn't
mine
um but then this kid you're the last
person i picture in my mia i know oh
rude
um
never mind uh i kept getting you know
how you can message people on planes
from other seats honestly no
someone kept messaging me during the
film a hundred times and wouldn't let me
watch the film because their message
kept pausing the movie and it was like
see f39 wants to chat
and after the fifth time saying no i go
let me see what f 39 wants to say right
now yeah so i was talking to the
stranger
they thought they were cute they
probably walked past you honestly that's
probably what it was i was just talking
to stranger i'm like well you got to
meet them somehow you know so what is
the bit yeah
the bit um
well
so you know after a long flight
this is how you're supposed to say it
you know after a long flight and you
turn off airplane mode and you check
your phone and you're like all right
here come the flood of dings about to
come in all my messages my notifications
i was sitting there waiting and i was
staring at it for a minute and i go
not one person honestly the reason why i
almost stole it because i actually had
the same thing happen to me when we
landed from that trip and i felt
horrible thank you that's all i'm saying
though honestly that's the reason why i
took it because i was like wait i will i
had that feeling happen was like well
that's why i thought it was funny
because there's god that i was sitting
there waiting for you know my ego to be
boosted with with the attention from
friends and no one cared yeah to text me
and then i caught myself
noticing that and i was like oh my god
hypothetically
huh like why do you why do i care and it
was so pathetic that i care it's so nice
when you come back and people are like
hey are you home or at least like do you
never know what happened like or what's
up with you
i mean sometimes it happens especially
this was like a longer flight so if it
was an hour flight i'd say all right i
was in my feels i was in my feels like
no one's gonna text me with them i have
to get on another flight tomorrow are
you gonna miss me yeah i am wait you
guys
are you really i am so yeah i actually
really sad because it's it's lonely i'm
gonna be by myself ryan's working a ton
this week oh yeah you are a ton yeah but
we're going to a football game now
everyone's gonna think we're a couple
and i have to make sure that i literally
have a sign that says we're related our
cousin does [ __ ] block us a lot yeah we
cockblock him too that's true yeah so
because it's over whenever we go out one
on one it's like it looks like we're
going on a date yeah whatever so we're
super excited about that go rams but
i am
really excited for you for this weekend
yes i'm gonna do it i'm so i'm going to
new york fashion week
and it's kind of uh
a weird feeling for me to go back
because everyone's probably thinking
that's cool why is it weird but
when i had the old pipe dream of trying
to be in that world when i was
i think the last fashion we go into when
i was 19. yeah honestly it was like the
lowest i've ever felt in my life yeah
and i was so sad and so depressed and
are you living in new york i was living
there and i just i hated who i was
honestly i just not that i did anything
but i just hated
the industry i was in i hated the people
that i was around i just didn't like
anything about it so now coming back as
a 23 year old for the first time since
then i'm excited because i feel like i
get to do a redo and and actually
spend the week doing and feeling my best
because we're confident you guys we're
feeling good about ourselves this time
around but it's it's weird it's a weird
feeling going back you know i feel like
you're also approaching this in a
totally different way because you're not
going as a model frick no like because
it's it's so i think it's like i i mean
i've i haven't experienced it but
knowing from what sistine's gone through
being a model going through new york
fashion week versus being more of an
influence or fashion because yeah
you're fascinated
i am no model and i am aware so don't
come for me right now in the comments
i'm aware but you know trying to be
you know and then being humbled really
quick i was like okay i get it guys she
but you know what you're my fault if
anyone was supposed to be in new york
it's must be you like you actually do
have a great style your body is banging
it also as a model body like you do fit
the frame of exactly someone that needs
to sit from earth no but i'm like oh
thank you no but i'm excited because
it's just like the whole energy in the
atmosphere and again yeah not doing it
with the pressure of trying to book
something but just going for the pure
enjoyment of yeah of meeting really cool
people and getting to work with really
cool brands you got to see all your
friends in new york too i know all of my
friends moved to new york i know what
the frick i'll be at home working on my
book club
speaking of book club
um oh you actually are genius because
okay i started this new trend that
actually kind of works
what
what you did at the wine bar the other
day oh my god i thought we were so
scared
oh my god you guys get into that too no
but no no not even about that but
okay
everyone attention
i have found
the best pick up way or pick up line or
pick up action i don't know in the
entire world like when i say
i was doing this purely because this is
something i like to do
i didn't realize
how attractive it looks and how everyone
wants to know who you are because you
are the main character this is such a
main character move it's a joke here it
goes
go to a bar restaurant
sit at the bar
order food order a glass of wine and
bring a book but it cannot be
a fun loud bar it needs to be a
strategic strategic restaurant bar
that's calm calm where you know people
probably go on dates here bar seating
essentials
not like i wouldn't say go to some like
fancy schmancy where everyone like gets
up you want to go in a place that's like
sexy low-lit
you would get a glass of wine there you
gotta sit at the bar yeah so i did it
because i it was a long day i had my
hair and makeup done i had my book with
me and i'm like you know i want to just
get off my phone no one was available
for dinner i'm like i don't i like
eating alone i was like i'll go alone so
i go or pinot grigio got my
bill bryson book about space and i'm
reading and i'm eating a salad i kid you
not
i got approached by four different guys
and there's something about it and each
one said it is so like one of them said
it's so refreshing to see
a beautiful girl reading it
what else did he say no listen no but
it's so refreshing to see
someone out reading a book and not on
their phone or yeah sitting by
themselves and someone was asking me
like what i was reading and someone they
all asked for my number
because
people think that that would make you
look weird or to feel uncomfortable but
honestly it does the opposite it is the
perfect open door
for anyone to approach you because right
off the bat if you're on your phone you
look more closed off than if you were
reading a book because a guy can go up
to you and say what book are you reading
i love that you're not on your phone i
mean there are a million ways oh i
haven't read that one
sexy you look confident without pushing
it you look intelligent yeah i mean you
look like you have so many things going
on in your life and they just want to
know you look like the biggest mystery
of them except i have to say
i feel like the books i read wouldn't
wouldn't work in that one no my books
would work you need to just bring one of
my books and pretend pretend to read it
i read it upside down i'm like please
please do it i'm kidding you not now i
just do it now i don't do it just to do
it to get guys
no truly truly she's like it's a bonus i
mean it's a i go to say it's a bonus but
it really is the cool thing and it was
funny because we talked about it with
someone that we knew and she brought up
she was like yeah i've done it so many
times and i think it works do it because
it's like a charm do it and let us know
if it actually works it does work
it's going to work i think you're
welcome for your love lives i think the
the book we should try it with the book
that you just recommended to me yeah can
i let's just like backtrack a little bit
so i don't know if you guys remember a
couple episodes ago cysteine was saying
to me she wants to read and i was like
oh my god my sister wants to read a book
and then she's asking for my opinion
well my genres are are two
murder
and sex yes so she said you can either
and i gave her all my greatest murder
books and she's like i'm out of it i
want erotica so i go okay i'll give her
a book that's called wallbanger right
readings reading she hated it because
apparently the sex didn't come until
like the last chapter i'm sorry it's not
an erotica if you to read 29 chapters
only to get the sex from the cat's point
of view okay sophia what is that i
didn't know how aggressive you wanted to
go with it so then i oh you know what
she could she's been [ __ ] on me
[ __ ] on me she prepared me with this
one no she was [ __ ] on me to
everyone like sophia gave the worst sex
book ever to me like she's bad at
recommending those books and i go you
know what
i'm like [ __ ] you i got the book for you
sophia went from a level one to a level
nine thousand nine thousand and um to
say this book
um the best way to describe it is
honestly should i just read the warning
yeah it comes before you know what i'm
not gonna do child's play with cecina
i'm gonna go
go from zero to 100 because you know i'm
sick of her telling me i don't have
steamy books
you guys
i opened this book it's called the dare
okay
and
i opened this book in the first page
there is a huge disclaimer
and i read the disclaimer out loud and i
was like sophia are you sure and she
goes yeah go read the reviews which i
will also read because they are
absolutely hilarious so i opened the
first page and this is what it said
this book contains intense fantasy
scenes of hard kinks edge play graphic
sex and harsh language okay we okay you
know fine
beware
this is a dark weird kinky read
activities depicted there and are
dangerous and are not meant to be an
example of realistic bdsm
reader discretion is advised
kinks and fetishes within erotic
humiliation fear play pain play knife
play
consensual non-consent orgasm denial
boot worship spanking crying blow jobs
clowns
group sexual activities i mean it goes
and blood play blood play
so right now i'm on chapter three and
the chapter is titled something like the
knife and i'm like oh gosh and the
chapter before was called the clowns so
i i just at this point i'm reading it
because i'm so curious he was so upset
about the cat seeing the point of view
of sexism okay fine we're throwing some
clowns and blood but i had to honestly
i'm reading it for the podcast i'm
reading it for you guys for content of
course but i thought i should read some
of the reviews
that people wrote about it just so you
guys understand how
how funny it is yeah
this person wrote holy smokes i don't
know if my ipad was smoking or i was i
wanted a cigarette after reading this
novella
i mean they're so they're so funny i
mean this one what in the [ __ ] name
did i just read in one sitting at 3 a.m
did i'm shocked you having on someone
wrote one of the hottest stories i
didn't even mind the clowns like it is
so funny they're like the clowns are odd
but
is it odd that i liked like it just i'm
telling you
if you if you're into the weird go for
it yeah let me know what you guys think
i think it's so funny yeah probably
please be above 18 if you're gonna read
this oh yes please do 18. yeah i'm not
back of anything this is the
yeah
and it's so funny because like
that's just not my vibe at all that's
not who i am i'm just not that great i
want erotic i'm like all right i'll give
you erotica
the most scary one that i couldn't
because you liked horror yeah any like
sex books so let's just
make that into a little combination you
nailed it yes thank you i'll let you
know thank you um i'll give you an
honest book review when i finish yeah
i'm excited we should probably go by
chapter by chapter and explain what it
what could do a live reading
oh
i don't know if everyone wants to know
your live reading of sistine talking
about clowns there has to have been sex
i see some nods okay let's [ __ ] you
i'm like there has to be someone out
there that might be into this um we
should do like character by character
like reading it to each other oh my god
yeah that'd be funny that that would be
a great idea right yeah okay let's do it
okay all right now you guys are going to
read the dare with us if you're not
unsubscribed i know they're all like
okay logging off now
i can't do you want to talk about how um
you just joined a fantasy league for the
first time yeah you guys i just joined
my first fantasy football league
i don't really know what i'm doing
you're the only girl in an all-boy group
yeah it's a 12 it's my cousin's friends
and one of them dropped out and he was
like do you want to join just pay x-men
dollars i'm like i'm in and he goes okay
do you know what to do i go nope and he
goes okay well i'll tell you the the
lowdown of it i don't understand during
draft day so i sat there for so long
also how do you boys do like
six different leagues and you sit there
for like eight hours doing like
different oh my god these take so long
we say that but we could watch i don't
know how many
hours of a youtube makeup tutorial
i would rather watch like eight hours of
housewives than sit and do this
six more times but it was fun um my
cousin said i had to choose running box
first um i didn't do that he was like
you need to choose all the people
because those are the ones who got
points i said i want to create the
cutest team so i honestly offer your
strategy is so funny sophia's going
based off of no stats no sets i don't
know anyway no prior knowledge of how
they used to play she's simply going off
of how attractive they are yeah well i
okay fair i i do watch hard knocks all
or nothing i do love football but i
don't know like who's the best all i
know is like tom brady is good so i
would say that's my that's my knowledge
to uh how
can you imagine if you beat this entire
group of football players i'll tell you
what happened based off of picking the
cutest i ignored their requests of me to
stop choosing the top like quarterback
or the top linebacker or whatever
i ended up getting the second most
project second projected to win which is
your strategy says something it says
something yeah
boys that are on my league or a team you
gotta give me those points i want to win
all that money i love it
get a new rug for our apartment
so that's what i'm gonna bank it on
that's too funny so this episode we are
going to skip the
bedtime story i know you're so sad but
just a quick reminder of how you guys
can submit your bedtime stories you can
either write them into the email that is
in our unwaxed instagram
unwaxed podcast gmail.gmail.com
and i think that's that's pretty much it
the unsolicited advice that sistine's
about to read you can go to apple
podcast give us a five star and write
your questions there i see y'all going
into the dm's trying to ask us questions
we're not answering it yeah sorry as
much as we want to
we need you to write it in the comments
and five stars also i saw that one star
about our audio quality yeah please
break here come on i'm gonna pnw for
life we're out for you what is that porn
for life what is that
yeah you yeah you one star on august
20th what's up with the awful audio
consistency
dude we apologize
every episode for it every episode we
were aware but now you there's no excuse
yeah so give us a better give us a break
but everyone else was great i read all
of them this morning you guys are so
nice abe from indiana
lenny lowe thank you guys so much for
writing in so yes if you want your
unsolicited advice answered make sure
you go to the apple podcast page give us
five stars and leave your question there
and we will answer and we actually will
answer we try to hit all of them why
don't you read it sophia all right this
is from sami
and it says my favorite podcast
of course thank you
um on wax with sophia and sistine
stallone is the best podcast i've ever
listened to each episode is so real and
genuine and you girls are always the
sweetest we love you guys and stay
amazing honestly literally warms my
heart i i say that every single time a
question i have for the two of you is
how do you guys deal with the haters and
how do you ignore the negativity coming
from them it can get super hard to do
that especially for me so i just want to
hear your guys's input thank you again
love you guys so much
i'll i feel like i go first me a few
months ago would not be able to answer
this question or feel
even
like i
i don't know like i don't know i
couldn't answer it but now i came with
it
i do i have a hard time
well i can say that i understand how
you're feeling because i think well this
is just a personality thing i
and if you follow the page you know i
love to like look up things research
read about it
pretty much like every daily mail
article my posts like i read through the
comments tick-tock
i just i can't help myself and it's
really bad habit and so unfortunately i
look at all of the amazing comments i
get and i fly by them and then i see one
bad one and it really sticks with me
that is exactly what i was going through
and that's what pisses me off and i was
realizing this and i think you said i
don't know if you said this or mom said
this the other day but i take it so
personally and i see it as a it was me a
yeah a flaw myself
and it's so stupid because like first of
all who are they to go online and like
say something rude when someone does
that right the advice that people
normally give is
oh just think about what they're going
through in their life but sometimes it
is really hard to think about a complete
stranger's feelings and what they're
going through and you can't relate to
them because you don't know who they are
or even if you do know who the person is
everyone has [ __ ] going on in their life
but
like you said i was the type of person
that would read the comments yeah have
99 compliments and only remember the one
insult and that's such a bad habit and
what i've started doing is completely
not answering or looking at anything
like out of sight out of mind i don't go
in the comments anymore i don't read the
mean
people that write to the daily mail i
don't do it anymore because you're not
ever going to leave your computer
feeling better about yourself ever like
unless you have the thickest skin in the
world i certainly don't i never have
left a comment section feeling better
well so if you can avoid that why not i
also like to say two things one
if anyone gets so much [ __ ] about how
they look who they are
look at sistine and i mean we get so
much hate on just every aspect of
ourselves we even get hate from people
in our inner circle in our circle like
yeah constantly so sammy you're
absolutely not alone like this is
happening to us happening so maybe find
some
comfort in knowing you're not alone in
that and then also i would say oh i had
something in my head i was gonna i'll
say this
hate and negative comments only bother
you if you let them
right so
i was trying to tell you this the other
day like you were
worried for someone else's feelings and
and you're bringing it on yourself and
and taking on everyone but i said to
sophia
it's not your responsibility to
satisfy everyone and and
however they throw things at you it's
your responsibility of how you inhale
them so if you let them bounce off of
you and say
i'm not going to let that person affect
me i'm not going to let them being sad
put guilt on me
it's all about how you take it also i do
sometimes and if you want to do
something that i can to make it more
comical you know how they do celebrity
mean tweets so you know every celebrity
has like horrible mean tweets oh my god
print it out read it out loud and make
it like a [ __ ] joke i used to do that
right now it makes me feel so much
better like i've had people say like
sophia looks like the ugliest one in the
family and i'll read it out loud and be
like all right like
and i'll put them i'll screenshot them
i'll put them in my close friends on my
instagram for my friends to see and i'm
like
which one do you guys think is like
steven gets a nose job cestine gets that
steen does this and i'm like which one's
the funniest you guys i don't know
literally so i think training your brain
to also make it sound like a joke and i
still have to work on this too i'm not
saying i'm perfect because i absolutely
still get in my head about these things
is one of the best ways so ignore it
make it a joke and remember it's nothing
on you it's all on that i promise you
either by the end of the day or the end
of the week you're not even going to
remember the words that were said about
you yeah like it's it's going to fly
over your head
wow
episode 49 baby
in you have to reach my hand i don't
want to lift it
i think i have an armpit stain you got
to come to me oh god well you guys this
was such an exciting episode we were
giddy with excitement coming in
you're such an [ __ ] um we were so
excited coming into this because it's a
oh god
it did the ghosts from our apartment
come out and follow us again i think so
okay we also have a ghost in the studio
we are so excited to be here you guys
this episode we've been looking forward
to for so long like thank malka again we
are really excited to announce you guys
someone really special episode 50
is going to be our biggest guest yet and
here it goes and it was a guest that was
quite hard to lock down
someone that you've requested i'm not
gonna give any more hints but it's gonna
be a big one so we will see you next
tuesday bye guys bye
[Music]